e da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono file j
siamo sulla rivista ragazzi siamo sua
piece in questo ottantunesimo episodio
per chi non sapesse perché il caso sta
roba
l'ho detto nel blog quindi chiusa
parentesi e che ora ragazzi comincia
allora non so che quanto schifo potrò
fare è più in versione hardcore qui mi
vendo impossibile come aggiungere un
livello di difficoltà è prevista
prossimo tarlo gioco col naso e vediamo
che cosa succede
faccio pagare cipro ragazzi veramente
incamminarsi su è secondo me ci ha
bisogno anche lui del jazz in realtà
ragazzi io ho aspettato sto momento da
da dana vita perché volevo provare a
giocare a chi visse con degli ostacoli
mettiamola così uk in due
lo so che ce la posso fare so che quando
finisci livelli col gesto c'è ancora più
soddisfazione c'è proprio una roba [ __ ]
alla fine che so più bravo così game che
normalmente mister chicken poi tutti ci
ha creato sto livello con la connessione
del kfc comunque già tran effetto sono
spaccato un braccio ma chi sei foto
anch'io non è un ministro
io sto guidando una bici con un braccio
staccato meraviglioso leggi o falsa
forza a non era profondo però forse però
fosse un precipizio
iolo non so se avete notato ragazzi ma
sto riuscendo a fare quasi qualsiasi
cosa col gomito che ha [ __ ] l'altra
gazich amica era lì giuro lanciava un
gesto se ce la faceva
2 ce n'è anche una 2 propria chiaro no
vabbè vabbè che grazie grazie
impossibile eccolo qua io stesso
riuscito a far tutto col con un braccio
figurazione scappare questo che dovrà
premere 75 tasti insieme spacebar pz me
cazzo faccio però la senape ha vinto
l'importante è salvare la senape ragazzi
minchia che testata come ma che car per
questo ho comprato regala il problema
non è quello problema che la [ __ ]
non passa nel buco invece è abbassata
problema è che devi andare brava brava
zia questore fatemeli vedere un paio di
livelli decenti che stava è un livello
fatto da shia la boeuf però ovviamente
vinto fritz trovo proviamo questo il
problema che non riesco a tirar n'è uno
più conciato così perfetto 2 non servono
un cazzo messi perfetto ok
e vabbè robe h
come ho fatto che sei diventato ed è
caduto
i polpacci ed insaccati così a voi chi
si alza pian piano che fa yoga proprio
spot the difference devo trovare la
differenza o che figo ciao ragazzi io
ste cagate le facevo sulla settimana
enigmistica la piccola prima corsa è la
nuvoletta che manca perfetto michele
bellissimo poi abbiamo il cappello la
bottiglietta le chicche tratte vicino al
menu donno ciak
cos'è che figlio che come ultimo ragazzi
abbiamo la candela giusto nella
settimana enigmistica stava a guardare
anni cioè questo è uscito in 5 secondi
overboard cosa c'è di over nuova beh
ragazzi marty mcfly ma non è un over
bordo è un over boardgame
senza questa va bene uguale sis agazzi
sto riuscendo a fare tutto con cos'è
cos'è col archi 6a sono io e oggi
prepariamo e l'altra in presenza di
ragazzi mi sembra di vedere scotto il
frullato sto guardando ex esatto questo
e maurizio merluzzo sono io che sto
mostra pagando la gente che bello tu
stai a caso verso il corpo prove ha
deciso di farsi sfruttare lo stesso
qualcuno mi spiega dunque che fisica
quest'uomo riesce a io non riesco
neanche a prender le posate che sta
cazzo di mamma ha cambiato la vita in
meglio sto livello super meat boy sul
serio nuovo hub è che figo ma sii serio
cari si fa tutto di sangue non averlo
sfigata cazzo faceva cagare anche nel
gioco vero l'opera faremo super meat boy
col gesso sempre meglio del gioco
normale è per carità stavo scherzando
dimostarto di quella [ __ ] di sua
madre
ma dai non miozzi com'è possibile mi
carlo con una mano ragazzi era è
un'impresa titanica lasciatemelo dire ok
no corso schivato
no dai ha vissuto ha ucciso per molto
meno allora frate vediamo donna e non ci
credo ma io non ci credo mai no ma ok
piano piano potrei sfidati la famiglia
in tre pezzi in tre pezzi zio bravo no
bravo no
brave li mortacci di tua madre o allora
dov'è il mio devi andare avanti
christian scazzo noi o no
seabra ho mica siamo riandati c'è una
fine in questa nicchia di livello che
cio l'ansia per favore grazie
non c'è una fine non arriverà mai alla
fine perché tua madre madonna fa i
panettoni manco valerio scambio e
fallout va beh siamo passati da super
meat boy a fallout madonna che mi sono
salvato il dottor mad men arriva quel
coso sai dove tornò in filo eppure nero
e o no no no no no no no no no che culo
quanto mi dispiace ho vinto ho vinto ora
che sono tutti così e tutti così a tutti
a prendermi per il culo cioè state nuovo
scherzando darvi ladri flap jack cosa
mia graffetta di apex asta guarda ho
fatto la performance del secolo non so
perché non mi allora e non è che lui non
ha capito come funziona ad abitarvi
pensa che sia una cosa di autolesionismo
ma non è così ma zio devi prendere
l'altro zio bravo devi spaccato troppo
po meno l'idea è quella un po meno
perfetto per non ti devi spaccare le
gambe però in teoria dovresti va mentore
ghadry en du in prova e vinci si va beh
spiegami come spiega micco vendite
spingiti come spinse tua madre spingeva
così trovate respinge sicuro se mi
dimeno come uno stesso ce la faccio
porcellato la [ __ ] bravo ce l'ho
fatto non so come non so come sono falsi
ciechi ed è stata va bene così fava
ragazzi prova a fare un paio di miei
livelli anche se sto conciato male ci si
prova ragazzuoli ci si prova cos'è devo
e la madonna
avg corsa morte facciamo l'ultima prima
che frigge faccio in tempo a leggere se
io mi per di gli perdoni discussi ma
cazzo
domani o mancati tutti al 26 traguardi
ion mancati tutti cosa fa
cosa fatta c'è solo il corso non ci
posso credere mai frater ai fratelli
trattava di tratterà di frate vai frate
vai frate
cos'è successo confronto che l'episodio
perché non ce la posso più fare
consigliatemi dei giochi da fare col
gesto voglio vederla difficoltà questi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto come
se vi è piaciuto al suo commento è un mi
piace la capacità di facebook e come noi
vidotto la prescrizione senza vestiti
schedine ci vediamo al prossimo video
beh ragazzi